Doki Doki
[Music]
welcome everybody to another episode of
ducky ducky literature Club what I
expected a cute horror game
a cute game turning into a horror game
what I got blue boss what the actual
Christian Channel okay I've been playing
this game for more than three hours and
absolutely nothing I repeat absolutely
nothing no indicator whatsoever that
this is a horror game has appeared in
front of me maybe some fourth wall
breaking some foreshadowing that
something bad is gonna happen but my God
the blue boss that has bestowed upon us
if something doesn't happen very soon
they might explode
ah that would be
uh where are we we're Monday Monday
Sunday
December 5th
here we go
[Music]
I've been getting increasingly anxious
about Yuri's upcoming visit right so
it's this the weekend we're gonna visit
Yuri or she's gonna visit us we're gonna
get it on hopefully I keep telling
myself there's no reason to be nervous
but it doesn't help much Yuri is clearly
an introvert and also an intimate person
in general there's no doubt that you'll
open up a little bit when it's just the
two of us Meanwhile we're even been text
we've even been texting occasionally she
was extremely apprehensive at first
but it wasn't long before I was already
learning more about her but putting Yuri
aside I haven't heard a thing from
sayori since she left the club early the
other day it's not like we text each
other all the time or anything but I've
been worried about her in the back of my
mind you can text her women
stupid between what Sirius said and what
Monica said is it really okay for me to
put serious feelings aside when she
might need any just text her hey girl
are you okay let's [__] not that hard I
decided to visit sayori oh okay so he
does it
before as Yuri comes over rather than
asking I simply tell her I'm coming over
much like you we've done in the past
once I reached sayori's house I knock on
the door before entering it myself
again we used to play so often that we
made it a habit of Simply entering each
other's houses like we were family
the house is quiet sayori isn't anywhere
on the first floor so I assume she's up
on her room it's already strange of her
not to run down and greet me I head up
to her room to her bedroom but I finally
find her
sayori
hey PTP
I sit down in her room
Siri forces a smile but it's easy to
tell that she's different
there's a minute of Silence between us
like this niggling team heavy
ah I guess you're right
what in the actual is that bird what is
that bird
it's been a long time not much has
changed has it
sayori's room is messy as it always been
I also recognize the same stuffed animal
and wall decoration that she's had for
years now
he moving me lifting he wouldn't be
sitting me
that's because I end up cleaning it for
you
how how come you certainly wanted to
come over today
aren't you supposed to see Yuri today
she knows
yeah but
wait how did you know that
sayori had already left by the time we
decided that last meeting
to me
preparation right I don't know I think
Monica is being a little sleazy a little
bit
yeah that's true
but what about you aren't you going to
be helping Monica today
[Music]
but I'm just helping early
we didn't plan to be
dipped ah so it's just me and Yuri then
yep
there's more silence between us
Cyrus stares in a random Direction
everything about her behavior is really
uncharacteristic
I finally get to the point
I just
wanted to see how you were doing
after you left on Friday
when something's wrong you can't hide it
from me I know you too well sayori so
iri Smiles shaking her head
that's new kids PTP
where can you just be looking for
whispering
me food
if I didn't get too weak it accidentally
expressed my feelings if it didn't make
that stupid mistake
then you would need to be weary to pick
me alone
he wouldn't have to come here
he would never even been thinking about
me right now
but this it is just My Punishment isn't
it I'm getting punished for being so
selfies
I think that's why the world decided to
have you can move it today
I just wants to touching me if
sayori
I grabbed sayori by the shoulders what
on Earth are you saying are you
listening to yourself right now
I know something happened to you
there's no other explanation for you to
be like this
so tell me already
until I know I won't be able to stop
thinking about it
[Music]
sayori gives me an empty smile
you really put me in a trip
[Music]
she gave me
nothing happened to me
he's just seeing in 2013.
it's like what Monica said she's only
cheerful around me and me us
[Music]
who cares about how we think about her
but really she carries her own demons
see sing what
are you talking about sayori
hehehe
you're really going to make me see it
Angie PTP
I can see him naturally system the thing
is
I've had really bad depressing me who
leave oh my I can't do that voice now
anymore Jesus the game just got real
did you know that
where do you think I'm late to school
Liberty
because smoothies I can't even find a
reason to get out of bed
quite recently said to do anything when
I fully know how Earthly the sayori
we're gonna go to school why eat why
make fruit why make other people put
their energy and caring to wait by
having them spend it on me
that's what it feels like and that's why
I just want to make everyone happy
without anyone wearing a meme
[Music]
I'm in shock
I can't even figure out how to respond
how is it possible that sayori kept this
from me the entire time that I've known
her
did she really want me once so badly for
me to just not think about her
why so Yuri
why is that that you never told me about
this
it almost feel like I've been betrayed
as your close friend because if I knew I
would have done everything I could to
support you
even if there's only so much I could
have done couldn't do
I would have tried a little harder to
make every day a lot better for you and
that's why I'm your friend
all you had to do was tell me
[Music]
where do you think to you
you told you then you would have to
waste every candy but me instead of
doing it pertin Jinx sorry
sorry
[Music]
God the worst moment
but it also feels like a bit being swung
against my head
this way I went so badly for you to make
friends with everyone here
helping everyone be happy together it's
the best thing for me but then I
discovered something is too
seeing you make friends and get closer
with everyone in the clue
it feels like a spear going through my
head but this way that's where you
decided the world just wants to teach me
if it's basically sniffing me
and
you're right
that I don't understand I don't
understand your feelings at all sayori
but I don't need to understand whatever
it takes for me to help you stop hurting
that's what I'll do
there's nothing nothing at all
the only thing that could help is if
everything could be like it always
but they were safely
I finally showed you with the herb
epitome
tears straight down series face
foreign
[Music]
Club because I was selfish
I was punished by my heart hurting in a
way that I couldn't understand
and now you came here and made you heard
too
this weekend tell me literally
and that's where I'm going to accept his
punishment
because I deserve every last one so
you're right without thinking I once
again grab some of his shoulders this
time I pull her in to a tight embrace
hey
Siri
I don't care if you feel selfish
I'm really happy that you convinced me
to join the club
seeing you every day makes it worthwhile
enough
if I make friends with everyone else
then that's just a bonus
but please never underestimate how much
I care about you
I wouldn't have it any other way
serious hey hugging me back
despite my arms being wrapped around her
sayori's arm remain at her sights she
started sobbing next to my ear
[Music]
boys
it's so wrong
[Music]
sayori barely manages to speak between
her Subs I don't know if I'm doing the
right thing
but all I want is for her to know that I
care
if you have it in
in you to call yourself selfish then you
have to let me be selfish too no matter
what it takes I'll figure out what needs
to change I'll make these feelings go
away
and if there's anything that you need me
to do then you better tell me I'll get
mad if you don't
and Antonio
I don't know
gently sayori finally puts her arm
around me in return
I don't know anything
it's already scary I don't understand
any of my feelings btb
the only time I'm not feeling the thing
is when I'm feeling pain but your hugs
are silver and that's really scary teeth
Sarah lets me go and she does so I let
go as well
fun right
yay
how would you like for me to spend it
all with you
[Music]
it's what I want I promise
I think there would be nothing
[Music]
yeah
sayori wipes her tea eyes
if I could spend the whole day here I
would of all days
this has to be the one I have other
plans
maybe I should cancel
but that didn't
it's almost time for Yuri to meet me at
my house
at the very least do you want to come
along and help out
it would be fun
to my surprise Sarah shakes her head
I'm Terry
I don't know if I if that would be very
good for me today
you understand rain
uh it's kind of hard for me to fully
understand but I'm trying my hardest
it's okay
way too much Betty
[Music]
all right
I look forward to
[Music]
poor sayori she was carrying demons
all this time I I say goodbye to sayori
in Exeter house on my way home I find
myself still feeling uneasy but it's
hard for me to keep thinking about it
when Yuri is about to come over too I
think Siri is right I shouldn't be
wearing too much and we're definitely
going to have a great time tomorrow
I should just focus on what's ahead of
me
as I approach my house I see something
that makes me feel a moment of panic
Yuri
I mean ah thank goodness
uh you're a little early
I'm sorry I wasn't home yet
were you waiting for a long time
no I just got here
but I started to get really nervous when
nobody answered the doorbell
you could have always texted me
if I'd known I would have reassured you
and heard more on my way home
ah I suppose that's true I didn't think
of that for some reason
it should be common sense to do that but
I decided to ignore it anyway let's go
inside
it's weird how the game
you know they talk about depression and
now they have this music playing in the
background it's like oh okay
[Music]
I can't drink
I see you brought a lot of stuff with
you
that's right
and did you manage to find everything
else you to buy as well yeah pretty much
at least I hope I got everything right
I'm sure it would be fine
I take Yuri to my room the first thing
she does is glance around curiously
which makes me feel anxious
it's so clean
[Music]
I cleaned it before you came over so
make sure there was no
[Music]
thanks sorry
uh
that's very considerate of you to do ah
no
it would I would be re I I would be
really embarrassed for my room to be a
mess while you were here hmm well I do
enjoy cleaning
is this really the right girl did we
really make the right choice
[Music]
uh I would have gladly helped you clean
ah
that would have been even more
embarrassing
wait don't look in there
I snatch you his wrist while it was in
the process of opening a desk drawer of
mine
ah I'm sorry
I wasn't thinking for some reason
I was just spacing out it's fine it's
fine
I let go of your viewers wrist she puts
both her hands firmly in her lap as if
making sure she's keeping track of them
so uh should we get started
ah yes
um I have a few things planned that you
can help with
decorations and other atmospheric
enhancements
atmospheric enhancements
you know
mood lightning
aromatheramy aromathermy candles wow she
brought that
oh wow I didn't know you plan on taking
it that far
of course
I wanted to help to take our guests
to a Faraway Place although many will
stop by just out of curiosity and for
cupcakes I guess
I'm determined to provide an experience
that would leave them wanting more
that's great
it's easy to forget that you're you're a
pretty intense person
ah
intense I guess that's the best way to
put it
is that a bad thing
no not at all I'm getting a little tired
and she kept talking about our patience
but I'm like I'm red you're getting a
little Annoying it's something that I
like it's something that I like about
you actually
is that so
that makes me feel relieved
and kind of Happy
yeah no need to be anxious you can relax
a lot
relax I brought some things for
relaxation
I was going to use them during the
Poetry event oh yeah like what let's see
Yuri rummages through her bag she pulls
out a few candles and a wooden cylinder
shaped object
I did some shopping on the way here so I
happened to have these in my bag
I plan to cover the windows in black
paper and use candles to lit the room
I think that would be amazing wouldn't
don't you
yeah that would be pretty neat
what's the wooden thing though
oh that's a dildo it's a diffuser for
essential oils of course
how familiar are you with aromatheramy
therapy not familiar at all
is that so it's one of my favorite
contributors to a positive atmosphere
depending on the oils or herbs you
choose you can change the mood of the
air itself
you even feel a permeate through your
body you can even feel it permeate
through your body
relaxation energy positive energy
romance reflection it's almost like
magic Yuri takes a cylinder and pushes
the switch on the bottom
in just a moment a thin Ray of vapor
begins to spout through a small hole on
the top
wow that smells wonderful what kind of
mood is that one for
this is a Jasmine essential oil for
relaxation
it smells a little sweet and Flowery
right yeah that's the best way to
describe it
I chose Jasmine for the event because it
provides more than relaxation Jasmine
enhances your emotions and helps you
feel them flow through your body you
feel warmer and your heart pounds more
heavily don't you think that would be
perfect for sharing our poems
does sound suitable
but you seem to know a lot about this so
I'll Trust your opinion about it
Yuri mood Smiles gently clearly enjoying
herself
she again reaches into her bag and pulls
out several spools of thin ribbon what
are those for well did you purchase the
origami paper I asked you to get yeah I
have it over here
we won't be using the paper for folding
origami
what I'd like to do is write a different
word on each paper
we'll need about a hundred of them Jade
says oh yeah
uh what will those be used for well I'm
going to cut pieces of ribbon to hang
from the doorway of the classroom
then we can fasten the paper onto the
ribbons to create a doorway curtain oh
my God that's amazing wouldn't that be
beautiful
and would it would also catch the eye of
those passing by the room it may attract
some to peek inside
that's really creative I had no idea
you'd be so good at this Yuri
it's that so well I suppose I get a
little intense as you put it
Yuri Giggles with red cheeks
is it just me or is she more relaxed
when it's just the two of us
maybe it's the way I fed that chocolate
to her like it was my it's like this is
excitement she feels from sharing
something that she enjoys
here's a Mark here's the market Pizza
pay you can rate any characters you want
I'll help you once I finish cutting the
ribbons ah
all right
sitting on the floor together the two of
us get to work I carefully draw a
different character on each paper doing
my best to manage my bad hat in writing
Yuri unravels a long strand of red
ribbon to her desired length then she
reaches into her bag once more and pulls
out a pocket knife
oh my God it's a horror game after all
the knife is Strangely Beautiful
what a what are you saying
the silver handle has an intricate
pattern of waves attached into it
the blade itself is gently tinted blue
that's no ordinary pocket knife and may
I say it looks really fancy ah well
embarrassed your looks away
what is it
you're going to think it's weird you
rate whatever it is I have no reason to
judge to age their own you know
if you promised you won't be waited out
yeah I promise
okay all right the thing is I'm kind
[Music]
of that's that's my thought thought out
you know
[Music]
you're a girl
oh that's great oh look at the tab it
would seem I have to go and find another
they're just so pretty
I can't help it [__] I promise not to be
weird enough
I don't know what it is
the combination of craftsmanship and
feeling of danger Maybe
what am I saying please don't think I'm
weird for this
you're laughing at me no no I'm not
laughing at you it's just funny how
nervous you get about sharing it's well
it it's an interesting thing to get into
I guess but I think it kind of Suits You
it's me yeah it's kind of intense
and besides this really cool looking
knife I can't deny that
it is isn't it you really relaxes her
expression once again
would you like to hold it sure
I'll check it out
Yuri carefully answer me the knife
with a handle facing me
take it and turn it around in my head
it feels heavy and extremely solid
where did you even get a knife like this
curious of its sharpness I feel the
point of the knife with my index finger
ow
did you do that
I didn't expect it to be this Sharp
I barely touched it at all
it's my fault
I should have warned you this knife is
extremely Sharp
it can cut through skin like it's paper
oh no
small drop of blood trickles down the
side of my finger
Yuri takes my hand and gives the wound a
closer look huh
she stares at it and noticeably fidgets
if you're squeamish I'll wash it off now
ah without warning Yuri puts my finger
in her mouth
and licks the wound
that's normal
[Music]
I feel her tongue curl around my finger
startled I instinctively pull my hand
back
[Music]
please forgive me I wasn't thinking
I
Yuri lowers her head her face burning
out
Yuri
that's the that's the most embarrassing
thing I've ever done
how could I have done how could I do
something like that
I'm sorry I'm sorry
ah
sure it was a little weird and it took
me by surprise
but I guess she was just trying to help
right
Yuri I think you're reacting a little
huh
she doesn't lift her head
what if she doesn't recover from this
for the rest of the afternoon all right
you know what this might be stupid thing
to do but I do it anyway
I take Yuri's hand and lick her index
finger in return
crazy B
did you really just do that
now we're even
Yuri looks at me like I did something
wrong
I knew that would be a bad idea if not
for the sweet Aroma of Jasmine oil the
air would be extremely heavy right now
[Music]
Yuri giggles shyly
hey
Yuri calling me [__] calling me weird
huh you calling me weird man I have no
response to that
where do you keep your bandages ah
I don't think I need one actually it was
a tiny cut look it already stopped
bleeding
I see that's relieving the tension is
quickly lifted we each resume our
respective activities I watch series and
I have cut through the ribbon like it's
nothing but air meanwhile I continue to
make progress on the paper
after we finish attaching the paper to
the ribbons we'll lay them all out side
by side it looks better than I expected
and will be very effective as a door
card
it looks great good thinking to come up
with this Yuri you invited all my
friends good thinking
ah thanks this is something I saw online
really
are you ready to move on to the next
task yeah let's do it what do you have
in mind
I'd like to create a banner that's why I
asked you to buy the paint tablets
Ah that's right one of the items you
read asked me to buy was a kid of
watercolor paint tablets we'll need
about six cups of water to put each of
the tablets in do you mind fetching
those for us of course not six cups of
water coming right up I'll be right back
in a minute
thank you very much
oh and just a little bit of water is
okay
if you feel the cups too much it will be
too diluted
taking yours advice I decide to use a
small plastic
small plastic bathroom cups rather than
full of sized glasses I put them on a
plate to catch any paint that drips then
brings it back into my room
Yuri yes
I oh
[Music]
she too damn
I come in to see Yuri quickly unrolling
her sleeve pulling it back over her arm
ah nothing
your face is a little red
is it too hot in here or anything
[Music]
ah no not at all there's nothing wrong
so
let's mix the paint
Yuri
hurriedly dismisses me and takes it upon
herself to unwrap the tablets dropping
them into the cups
so
I thought we would do something simple
that would look very nice
I like to paint a gradient across the
banner
starting with the colors for a sunrise
Then daytime then Sunset and nighttime
once it drives I'll write an
inspirational quote across the banner
we can hang it on the wall behind the
podium at the front of the classroom
oh neat I need
what are you gonna write
well
it might be more fun to surprise you
yurish Smiles at me if you say so
after rolling out the banner Yuri and I
kneel on opposite sides so we don't get
in the way of each other Yuri uses a
brush and adds a few dots of different
colors across the banner to serve as a
color guide when we paint
this kind of reminds me of elementary
school
painting on a banner with watercolors
feels a lot like art class products we
had back then it's relaxing
huh I'm sorry if this feels too childish
no I didn't mean that at all it's kind
of fun you know
I'm glad you feel that way too
Yuri stops painting for a moment
thinking to herself
for me I don't need to go out and do
crazy things to have fun in fact I
usually don't even want to
I just like when I can spend time with
one other person even if it's something
simple like reading it doesn't even
matter if we don't talk much just having
a friend next to me makes me feel a
little bit nicer
I think that's all it takes for me to be
happy
is that so
even if Yuri and I are quite different I
can understand where she's coming from I
feel that way about things like anime
games where simply sharing the
experiment with someone can make me feel
happy make me happy
I think I feel the same way
Yuri Smiles gently
I knew you'd understand
Yuri leans over the banner to grab an
unused paintbrush but I move at the same
time causing my head to bump into hers
sorry here he reels back Yuri reels back
and I quickly lift my hands in Surprise
are you hurt no no I'm not hurt
it just started me that's all
sorry I should have asked you to get it
for me it's not your fault
yeah oh your face
there's drop level of pain on your ass
face and neck
is there something wrong on my face yeah
I accidentally got paint on you
sorry it's totally my fault I'll get a
towel right away I rush out and fetch a
small towel then I dampen it with hot
water I returned to my room nailed back
down in front of her
cat
[Music]
ah cute
here
I pat down Yuri's face and neck with the
towel
[Music]
wow
is something wrong it's hot I just
didn't expect it
sorry I didn't want to use cold water
having finished I started to retract my
hand but Yuri suddenly holds my wrist
[Music]
crazy
wait
hey just for a little longer
it feels really nice
ah I keep my hands still against Yuri's
neck
she looks into my eyes
it's an intense expression that I
recognize from when she reads her books
almost as if she's lost in a date
enveloped by her own thoughts she
breathes gently half through slightly
parted lips
what is happening
is it the aroma of the Jasmine all
giving me this dizzy feeling
[Music]
here is gentle's finger wrapped around
my wrist sent a tingling sensation
through my arm
suddenly her face seems to be much
closer to mine than it was just a moment
ago kiss her
ah
Yuri slowly pulls away
[Music]
sorry
feeling a little light-headed today
I didn't mean to space out it's fine
the moment is over soon as it began
Yuri picks up her brush again but her
movements seem clumsier like she's
unable to focus I remain silenced forced
to ignore the event that just transpired
I accidentally retrieve my own brush and
continue following Euros example
that should do it I finished filling the
night sky with a white dot with white
dots that look like stars looking at the
banner as a whole it's very pretty and
natural looking
I think it came out better than I
expected I'm really happy with the
results yeah me too
are you gonna add the lettering now ah
not yet I need to it needs to dry first
that's true but won't that take a while
perhaps it would be best to leave it
here
then have you bring it in the morning
I can do the lettering in the classroom
before our event starts is that okay
that's totally fine wonderful in that
case I don't think there's anything more
for us to do here I can think of a
couple of things
phew
[Music]
you say that like your glad it's over
was I wrong to assume that you were at
least enjoying yourself a little bit
no that's that's not that it's I'm I'm
just glad that we managed to get
everything done
see I am too I was a little concerned
about time I need to start making dinner
soon
ah so you don't have any time left
I was secretly hoping we would have
extra time after finishing work
well
Yuri thinks to herself
I think it would be too responsible of
me to wait much longer I'm sorry
I was hoping there would be more time as
well
it's probably my fault sorry for being
such a slow worker
no that's not it at all
and the important thing is that we got
everything done right
yeah
so I should be I shouldn't be
disappointed or anything
Gathering all her things Theory seemed
to look a little downcast I understand
why it sounded like she rarely gets the
opportunity to spend time with friends
in a relaxed environment but that
doesn't mean this is the last time it
can happen
[Music]
I feel like just because they said that
it definitely is
when Siri packs up I walk her at the
front door thank you very much for
having me today no problem I'm glad I
was able to help just let me know if
there's anything else you need me to
bring tomorrow I will well then Yuri
fidgets I guess I'll see you tomorrow
wait
I kind of say that without thinking
about today
it's fine that we didn't have as much
time as we wanted because we can do this
again
whenever you want you can come over we
can go out somewhere
I forgot you don't like going out much I
forgot that you okay we're asking her
out this is good it's a stumble over my
words Yuri Simply Smiles bashfully
anyway
you know what I'm trying to say so
you are very thoughtful Pizza Yuri takes
a step closer to me then briefly
squeezes my hand
kind of like that about you
well
how am I supposed to respond to that
I don't even get a chance to
as Yuri suddenly pulls back sayori
uh oh
oh
no
no oh
[Music]
is
key BCP sayori
just know we weren't easy
it is stupid to see hey
um
well it's nice to see you I'm sorry but
I I'm already on my way to leave
hey really that's TV
I'm sorry
but we'll all be together at the
festival tomorrow so
that's so that's fine right
[Music]
beams
yeah so
I'll see you tomorrow
clearly embarrassed Yuri hurries off
sayori wave goodbye after her
[Music]
I thought you didn't want to come over
today
[Music]
I try seeing me dream
but my imagination was being really mean
to me
so we had to come here and see it for my
thing
see what
what are you talking about
you know
how much fun you were having with you
here and how close you got to her it
makes me really
[Music]
Yuri
and you mean such kid
friends
they truly Minister me
tears starts to fall down sayori's face
[Music]
why did he feel like my hair is bleeding
again it is the meat if you think it's
in me
so you're rep you're saying that
[Music]
therapies we need to keep with rain hey
she Juiced what what did Monica tell you
Monica Monica was right about white
sayori
what I said before is true I'm not gonna
let this continue caring about you like
this is isn't the burden your mind is
making it out to be it's something that
makes me happy it's something that I
wouldn't trade for anything else so even
if it takes an entire lifetime I'm gonna
be by your side until you don't feel any
more pain
bit [__] sairo looks away
I put a hand on her shoulder to reassure
her
what are you scared of sayori
I'm skating
but I might like you more than you like
me
Theory
it's true Whitney
and with the weekend started to like you
too much and did it to myself
busy with you
that's enough Siri
I don't want you to hurt anymore
I slide my hand down so you always are
and squeeze her hand in my own
do you remember how I said I always know
what's best for you
still believe me
wordlessly sorry nuts
even if you don't understand all your
own feelings I know what you need the
most right now and that's what I'm gonna
give it
going to give to you
oh wow
I gotta make a save here I'm making a
save at all the choices
so far there's only
there's really only two of them
[Music]
friend zoned you have to be honest you
can't love someone out of sympathy
you know
foreign
s to be like they've always been Monica
told me the truth she told me how much
happier you seemed after I joined the
club
I know you're struggling with some
really difficult feelings right now but
please trust me that I know what's best
and what will make you happy in the end
I promise I'll help get things back the
way they were
hey I see
sayeri forces a smile through an
incredibly pain expression
[Music]
I should write a poem about this
sayori it's okay this is just my
punishment
remember
[Music]
please please don't worry about these
stupid feelings
I know you're right
I knew this whole time that there's no
happiness damn that peace that's why you
keep me just so I could get the answer I
needed to hear and the other thing
you're also right that I just wanted to
go back to the way it was I realized I
knew I really do know you really do know
me better than anyone bgp
I trust you with anything
anything at all
sayori smile finally breaks all of a
sudden she turns around and dropped to
her knees
hey
[Music]
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I don't know
how to make that sound clutching her
head with both hands she screams as
loudly as she can
I'm so shocked I don't know how to act
react Sarah looks over her shoulder and
flashes me one more weak smile before
turning around and running off sayori
I'm left helplessly standing in front of
my house why am I feeling so horrible
about this
there's nothing more that I could have
done the most I can do is support sayori
through her feelings and help her on the
path that's right but I'm having as much
trouble understanding Sarah's feeling as
she is even though I can comfort her I
keep wondering if I should be doing
something more or something different I
know these thoughts will continue to
plague me and so things start the way
back the way they were I'm going to give
it everything I got sorry will always be
my dearest friend and I'll do whatever
it takes to put a smile on her face
every day
it's the day of the festival
of all days I expected this one to be
the one where I'll be walking
to school with sayori but seryori isn't
answering her phone
I considered going to her house to wake
her up but decided that's a little too
much meanwhile the preparation for the
event should be nearly complete the
banner Yuri and I painted is dry and I
gently rolled it up to take with me
she sent me a pleasant text reminding me
not to forget everything and I reassured
her
funnily enough I probably feel the same
way as natsuki about Daemon
I'm more excited for it to be over so I
can spend time with sayori and Yuri at
the festival but knowing Monica I'm sure
the event will be great too
Pizza
first one here
thank you thanks for being early
sorry one sec
I feel like she's she's hiding something
for sure
that's funny I thought at least Yuri
would be here by now
Monica is placing little booklets on
each of the desks in the classroom
they must be the one she prepared that
has all the poems we're performing in
the end I found a random poem online
that I thought Monica would like and
submitted it so that's the one I'll be
performing
I'm surprised you didn't bring sayare
with you yeah she overslept again that
dummy
you think that on days it's important
she'd try a little harder
I say that but I suddenly remember what
sayori told me yesterday and I suddenly
feel awful knowing it's not nearly that
simple for her I only said it because
it's the way I'm used to thinking but
maybe I should have gone to wake her up
after all
you should say you should take a little
responsibility for her Pizza I mean
especially after your exchange with her
yesterday
you cannot let her hang in this morning
you know
exchange Monica you know about that of
course I do I'm the club president after
all
but
I stammer embarrassed
did sayori really tell her about it that
quickly
about how I basically turned down her
confession that makes me really seem
like the bad guy here
but I'm the one who knows what's best
for her right geez
you don't know the full story at all so
don't worry
I probably know a lot more than you
think
uh Monica is being as friendly as usual
but for some reason I felt a chill down
my spine after hearing that
hey why don't you check out the
pamphlets they came out really nice
yeah sure
I grabbed one of the pamphlets laid out
on the desk
oh yeah they really did
something like this will definitely help
people take the club more seriously yeah
I thought said
I flipped through the pages each
member's poem is neatly printed on its
own page give it an almost professional
feel
I recognize natsuki and Yuri's poem from
the ones they perform during our
practice what's this I flipped to
sayori's poem it's different from the
one she practiced
it's one that I haven't read before
oh
get out of my head before I do what I
know is best for you get out of my head
before I listen to everything she said
to me get out of my head before I show
you how much I love you get out of my
head before I finish writing this poem
but a poem is never actually finished it
just stops moving
damn
ah what is this reading the poem I get a
pit in my stomach pet what's wrong
and nothing
this poem feels completely different for
anything else sayori's written but more
than that
I I changed my mind I'm going to get
sayori so ah where all right try not to
take too long okay
I quickly leave the classroom
don't strain you said Monica calls that
out after me I Quicken my pace
what was I thinking
I should have tried a bit harder for
sayori it's not a big deal at least to
wait for her or help her wake up even
the simple gesture walking her to school
makes her really happy besides I told
her yesterday that things will be the
same as they always have been that's all
she needs and what I want to give her
I reached Sarah's house and knock on the
door I don't expect an answer since
she's not picking up her phone either
like yesterday I opened the door and let
myself in
sayori
she really is a heavy sleeper I swallow
I can't believe I ended up doing this
after all waking her up in her own house
isn't that more like something a
boyfriend would do in any case it just
feels right
outside sayori's room I knock on her
door sayori
wake up dummy
there's no response
I really didn't want to have to enter
her room like this
isn't it kind of a breach of privacy
but she really leaves me no choice I
gently opened the door
oh
no
[Music]
I don't know
foreign
[Music]
an exception has occurred
file game script chapter 5 line 307 see
Trace back text
for details
[Music]
oh my God
Trey's back
[Music]
here it is here's the text I found it
I'm sorry but an uncaught exception
occurred while running game code
[Music]
oh geez I didn't break anything did I
hold on a sec
I can probably fix this I I think
actually you know what this would
probably be a lot easier if I just
deleted her she's the one who's making
this so difficult
well here goes nothing
[Music]
oh geez I didn't I didn't break anything
did I oh hold on a sec
actually you know what it's probably a
lot easier if I just deleted her she
just wanted making this difficult here
goes nothing
[Music]
we're gonna end
that episode there
I
I'll see you tomorrow
with another episode
Squad